she was a very great person in my life
since she'd been in a hospital
day night i was praying
she was battling you know this
with this deadliest disease you know i
mean
finally she can't go
she was really fighting with this five
weeks in the hospital
and this has left you and your five
girls what impact has this had on you
all
yeah this impact
the chain complete in my
life you know what i mean just
since that's happened i'm thinking how
do i cope with this you know and she
never got to hold her new baby did she
no
she didn't even know you know
she had a baby girl or boy or nothing
the man think you know they
which is shocking
she didn't had a chance to talk to me
you know
five minutes even you know to tell
me about the
daughters you know what you do after me
what were her last words to you
i can't remember because
she can't even talk you know since she
left the house
so
her breathing prob
problem you know what i mean so she
can't breathe properly so you can't talk
get the vaccine
otherwise you know it's gonna be very
very hard for them you know
they're gonna chant completely your life
it's a very deadly disease you know
was she planning to get the vaccine
after she'd had the baby yes
yes
she planned
so many things
and this disease didn't give her a
chance to